Nature has many lethal predators who
would love to eat you
most of these are animals but what about
plants well there's one plant that
thrives in boggy areas and has a taste
for insects the Venus flytrap what would
happen if a giant one trapped you could
you survive
how long would it take to be fully
consumed and do venus flytraps actually
like the taste of humans this is what if
and here's what would happen if you were
swallowed by a Venus flytrap in some of
our other videos we've looked at what
would happen if you were swallowed by a
whale or even an anaconda well how about
a carnivorous plant venus flytraps
mainly get their energy from the soil
but to stay healthy they need to eat a
few insects per month during the growing
season okay so you're not an insect but
a giant flytrap might not be able to
tell the difference so how exactly would
it eat you the Venus flytrap has three
stiff trick homes that are like
sensitive hairs on each of its inner
leaves when they get touched the plant
gets interested but it won't snap shut
immediately if a little piece of dirt or
a leaf lands on it the plant will ignore
it and stay open but when something or
someone bends these hairs more than
three times like a fly or a terrified
human its mouth snaps shut trapping its
prey this trapping motion is called
thigma nasty and it's very nasty indeed
in this scenario you'd probably want to
play dead for about 12 hours if you're
lucky and very still the trap might open
but what if you weren't so lucky
once you're in its grasp the Venus
flytrap will stay shut to keep bacteria
out of its leaves it squeezes tightly
around you while secreting an antiseptic
juice to stop you from turning rotten
you'd essentially be pickled mmm mmm
yummy
once inside you would be completely
sealed like some sort of biological
coffin with little oxygen you'd probably
pass out pretty soon if you try to
escape any movement will provoke the
plant to start producing enzymes and
highly acidic digestive fluid these
enzymes will absorb any sodium you might
have in your body
helping the venus flytrap transport
nutrients plants generally don't like
sodium but the flytrap needs it to
survive humans are also rich in
phosphorus and nitrogen which are vital
to the plant's survival and lacking in
its natural environment after about five
to 12 days of digesting you the plant
would be back open for business
whatever's left of you would likely be
washed away by the rain or blown away by
the wind so what makes the Venus flytrap
so appealing to its prey well the plant
produces a sweet nectar that's
irresistible to bugs making the flytrap
a perfect natural insecticide for
gardeners that want to avoid adding
chemicals to the plants if there are a
lot of mosquitoes where you live it
might be a good idea to plant a bunch of
these around your home
some companies have tried selling the
flytraps extract as a homeopathic
supplement claiming that it fights all
kinds of ailments but these claims have
been mostly debunked so don't get
trapped into thinking it will solve your
medical problems the real question is
could scientists actually grow one big
enough to eat a human well they'd have
to manipulate the plant's DNA it would
take a 120 foot long Fly Trap to catch a
6 foot human which probably isn't going
to happen anytime soon fly traps have
been known to die from severe
indigestion when fed ground beef so
chances are they wouldn't find you very
tasty either frankly I'd be more
concerned about falling into a pool of
piranhas but that's a story for another
what if